gilles verdez des infos bon là pourquoi
pourquoi cette fois c'est tombé comme ça
alors ça a été très houleux la décision
était prise depuis plusieurs jours et le
fait que yannick jadot après valérie
pécresse refus ça a été le coup de grâce
ce qui se passe c'est que il ya une
enquête interne et le groupe altis qui
chapote a pris cette décision parce
qu'ils craignent d'autres révélations
voilà c'est ça la vérité qui est j'ai
pas dis que j'en aurai j'ai dit qu'ils
craignent d'autres révélations
blanquette en interne commence pour le
moment il n'y a pas de témoignage mais
ils craignent que l' enquête judiciaire
du commissariat du xvième arrondissement
aboutissent à des choses et donc pour la
sérénité du groupe ils lui ont coupé la
tête et a marqué dans le communiqué
temporairement écarté de l'antenne
pourquoi ces juridique ça les
invocations de sa wii si vous mettez
quelqu'un au placard temporairement vous
pouvez encore négocier parce que jean
jacques bourdin n'exclut pas de faire
appel à ses avocats tout de suite et les
procéduriers il a tout à fait le droit
comme s'ils savaient était définitive la
rupture du contrat de travail ils
attaquent ils gagnent
temporairement s'aménage pour le groupe
une décision à l'amiable mais je vous le
dis très clairement je pense qu'on ne
reverra plus jean jacques bourdin
et voilà que vous avez des arts fouille
alors que sur des suppositions ne
reverra au passage en sait rien en
revanche si à trois raisons
effectivement que mon comment donner la
chaîne la première c'est que c'est le
présentateur de la présidentielle or
aucun des candidats de la présidentielle
aujourd'hui ne veut venir l'affronter
avec par les éditions déjà il ya un
petit problème
jadot
jadot et puis on off pour l'instant les
autres candidats ne souhaiterait pas
venir non plus face à lui a donc déjà 6
1 il est là pour ça donc c'est
impossible la deuxième raison en effet
c'est que le journaliste qui a écrit le
pape urbain parisien va sortir un autre
mail à pied prochaine map sûr mais
qu'elle est visiblement il ya d'autres
noms dans le papier d'autres personnes
d'autres ramés et la direction est au
courant de ce papier des règles du
papier qui va arriver quand les derniers
arguments il a quand même du sens c'est
qu'à tout moment les potes il peut être
appelé par la police a entendu par la
police et comme il déplace en province
notamment pour préparer l'émission l
affaire si à ce moment là il est
convoqué par la police il pourra pas y
aller cet argument j'y crois moins mais
c'est vrai il donne la chaîne en tout
cas les civils de toute manière la
raison était très très simple que j'ai à
dire fait qu'il soit coupable ou pas les
candidats
ils ne veulent plus affronté qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire va pas laisser tout le
monde se barre et son seigneur bon ben
voilà monsieur non mais le coup de grâce
il avait déjà enlevé la matinale mois
déjà quand il eut enlevé la matinale
pour mettre à pauline de malherbe je me
suis dit déjà d'or oui d'accord mais
c'est sûr mais en attendant c'est déjà
déjà un signe qui vous qui comptait plus
blondin après si comme tu dit dans le
parisien il ya d'autres affaires qui
vont éclater effectivement là tu peux
plus afin de savoir pour moi sur bfm rmc
il écrit laquelle 72 ans thumann 112 72
ans c'est fini il refera plus sur la ram
c'est d'ailleurs lui ne voulait pas
d'appeler l'antenne alors on va alors
oui lui ne bouge pas un seul élément pas
quitter la menait alors il a réagi
décision unilatérale de la chaîne that
parce que lui il voulait s'accrocher
encore est resté coi qu'il met
exactement je regrette la décision
unilatérale du groupe bfm tv et rmc de
me retirer des antennes pour prévenir
des risques d'instrumentalisation de la
pinte dont je fais l'objet je rappelle
que je conteste les faits qui me sont
reprochés et déplore que le principe de
présomption d'innocence soit ignorée yum
mais c'est ça il dit qu'il vit ça comme
une injustice et moi franchement je le
comprends s'attaque aujourd'hui à
l'heure du tribunal médiatique il suffit
d'un tweet d'un article d'un invité qui
plante pour potentiellement briser votre
carrière et pour moi ce qu'a fait
yannick jadot c'est grave parce qu'on ne
venant pas sur le plateau ils bafouent
complètement la présomption d'innoncence
accord néanmoins je pense qu'il
reviendra à l'antenne parce que là cumul
l'accumulation des affaires de type mhi
tout fait qu'on a tendance à les oublier
et ça passe avec le temps je pense qu'on
peut le ranger
dans le papier du parisien également on
apprend vite qu'il vit cette décision
comme une injustice il est curieux ce
qu'il vit est terrible c'est son
intégralité sur laquelle il a bâti toute
sa carrière qui est directement touchée
où matthew et moi ce qui me choque
effectivement c'est pas du tout ce que
fait la chaîne la prochaine ll
différents qui sont coupables ou
innocents on peut pas le garder il va
pas interviewer personne ni sera face à
personne or son de son métier sadc
d'interviewer les candidats à la
présidentielle ce qui me choque
effectivement ce sont les candidats à la
présidentielle qui est ohana un café
jadot s'est mis non pas encore
j'avais déjà dit ce que je pensais de
lier de pécresse et pareil pour jadot
pour le moment on est en train de parler
d'un monsieur qui pour le moment encore
une fois parle d'une femme qui l'aurait
agressée il n'y a pas de preuves parle
d'une acier d'une accumulation de sms
pour l'instant il ya 15 cm
il est en train de piétiner la présente
je n'attendais nommé sauf que si au
genre des agressions faites aux femmes
par exemple oui si l'on ce sujet là oui
comment ils se positionnent parmi en
connaissant ces pandémies sont sauvés
mais pas coulé on peut
déjà condamné c'était horrible lorsque
tu es une somme non maintenant je dis
que ça ça ça laisse un voile compliqué
malgré tout sur le débat et qui va mener
forcé ne sais pas mais voilà justement
la caf et de la justice française est
seulement ne condamne pas les gens avant
d'être là pour faire la morale et oui
pas les hommes politiques et morales
vous n'êtes pas d'ensilage de maïs sur
roger d'accord non qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire que c'est absolument
intenable et revenir sur les mots de
jean jacques bourdin pourquoi il dit
décision unilatérale ses avocats qu'il
préside a ôté unis la terrasse aux beaux
que d'un côté quand vous subissez une
décision unilatérale vous pouvez
éventuellement après il faut demander
alors c'est le mans dans la gamme avec
lui que d'un côté mais pouvait prédire
seulement moral voilà pourquoi yagladadi
la mère de celle ci
il ya un précédent récent d'arrivée
franchie bas sur elle il est revenu mais
le raid a été faite il a été un coup d'
il
révélé
et toi tu crois ici
les revenus donc enfin moi je
rapprocherais toujours agent green
bovins à avoir compris qu'il devait
s'écarter de l'antenne c'est injouable
pour les pressés d'aller pour les
propulsions cinq ans je suis sûr ils y
sont arrivés
c'est injouable la mairie pécresse a
fait un laïus très très bien qu est ce
que font les autres alors lié aux ados
c'est un homme il fait pas de la russie
s'en prend plein la figure on dit bonne
chance me voilà siperian et à la nuit ce
sera forcément bien
raisonné pour moi c'était intenable les
foires et écrits sont pas dus
je leur disais qu'il n'est pas coupable